in the summer of fat
um they're filling a Reese's Peanut
Butter Cup like they're there should be
laws now with some of the restaurants
like there should actually be laws I'm
actually I believe a little bit like you
know Michael Bloomberg towards the end
of his run got very Nanny state
he started to behave like a petty
dictator he wanted to ban smoking and
ban large sodas and I think he didn't
really even love vehicles in the city
like he wanted just it to be simply
pedestrian like he had a lot of ideas
that were kind of infringing on people's
personal freedom but maybe this is why
people can't have personal freedom let
me the Reese's Peanut Butter Cup is the
best candy in the world it has been for
years why why ratios
ratios it is a perfect ratio of
chocolate to peanut butter that's not a
novel concept I'm sure I've said it
millions of people have said it that's
what makes things good ratios sandwiches
what makes them good ratios how much
meat how much cheese how much bread how
much whatever
there is this peanut butter cup is
absolutely perfect as it is it should
only be altered maybe once a year during
Easter for that egg which isn't good
where they put it in the form of an egg
because of the holiday and because of
Christ but maybe that's the only time we
don't need to do like Oreo
I think kind of bombed when they tried
to go too crazy and we got to ban the
Franken food
like the Oreo cakester that's like it's
a cake it's not it's a cake that's
shaped like a cookie that you eat
you it can't happen now we have a
problem in this country like a very big
problem we have to ban Franken food
things that like the donut Burgers like
the things that aren't of nature not
that a peanut butter cup grows on a tree
but you know what I mean the things that
push it to the edge
where it's heinous where people look at
it and there's a Grimace on their face
because they can't even imagine eating
this crap we have to use the power of
the government now to stop this
stop the pop-ups in Times Square
you don't need like there was an m m
store now every candy
cereal there's a pop-up experience where
you can go in and with your children
and and feed them garbage in like a fun
disney-esque environment
it we don't need it anymore and I I
think it's hurting people
so now here's the article that that made
me con it's convert I'm fully converted
to this by the way I fully but you will
not find this in Europe
you will not go to France and and and
and have stuff your own one pound giant
Peanut Butter Cup
stuff your own one pound
happy summer by the way do you know
sweaty by the way in a majority of the
country right now you can't even walk
outside because it's so hot your tits
are sagging and there's a rash under
your tits right now most people not all
of them but a lot of them statistically
they're they have a tit rash
gender unimportant they have a a a a
rash and they are ignoring and they're I
guess smearing Eucerin on it so they can
go walk to get the big one pound Peanut
Butter Cup
show the video of this it's the most
disgusting thing I've ever seen
it is like the self-serve frozen yogurt
concept which I had a great bit on in my
first Comedy Central half hour that I
believe is available in Canada right now
because uh they did not show it anywhere
or Market it thanks Comedy Central
appreciate it now
um that being said
there is a uh the self-serve frozen
yogurt concept is you go in you choose
it's like Chipotle you know you choose
the mix-ins you choose the things you
eat this is failed miserably by the way
this idea that Americans should be able
to choose that's why the burritos at
Chipotle can't close that's why the
self-serve frozen yogurt costs 38
because Americans cannot handle the
freedom of choosing what goes in their
body it needs to be banned now Reese's
has something called stuff your cup
which is disgusting
families that go to this this should be
like to catch a predator they should go
right to jail a family that takes their
fat kids to stuff their Reese's cup
should go right to jail afterwards
because everybody's going to be a
legless Pig very soon
I'm telling you
I'm at least writing a novel
on my parents for what they did
to me with food
save yourselves
resist off your cup let's let's watch a
little bit of this please Chocolate
World in Hershey Pennsylvania you can
make a custom one pound Reese's Peanut
Butter Cup
[Music]
choose from a variety of your favorite
mixes so listen how sick this is by the
way so it said Hershey is it at is it
the theme park yeah
so it's in Hersh what they call Hershey
Park yeah so in Hershey Park there's the
peanut butter cup experience or whatever
stuff your cup
it's a one pound chocolate cup
they put peanut butter in it this is
where it gets a little bit like Being
John Malkovich
they put crushed up peanut butter cups
in the cup
so you have a cup made of chocolate and
then peanut butter and then crush the
peanut butter cups in
the cop with Reese's Pieces and other
things
I mean you you and they're eating this
it's 90 degrees it's 90 degrees and
they're eating it
it's 90 it's melting all over their
faces and they're eating it let's keep
watching
watches they're folded in the fresh
peanut butter direct from the factory
right down the road
it's like Cold Stone but they do with
peanut butter
[Music]
peanut butter is then transferred into a
cup made of real chocolate food we add a
few more toppings oh
and then the chocolate lid what who's
this for it has been wrapped and ready
for you to take home to share or keep
all to yourself what
why would they even make that joke
you could take it home to share
or
I mean that that that's truly and I've
eaten some bad stuff and I know that
doesn't shock anyone that is bad
you cannot be taking your kids
you cannot be taking your kids to that
if you have any love
for them as parents
you have to tell them no
Mommy Daddy can we go to stuff your cup
no we can't
no we can't and you know why this is
what you tell them because the people
that are going to stuff your cup are
going to be dead
do you want to be dead do you want to be
dead soon
no okay we're not going to stuff your
cup
cause you're gonna drop dead tell them
use the word you're gonna drop dead if
we give you a big cup of peanut butter
with look at that potato chips
and bacon I'm looking at potato chips is
that bacon
you can put potato chips and bacon bits
and fold them into peanut butter
I mean I I gotta be honest it's it's so
it doesn't even seem good
but that's where we're at now with food
it's like the new foods
are so over the top they know people are
going to get mad by the way where's the
outrage of this it's a cancel that you
canceled Dylan Mulvaney and Bud Light
how about canceling these people they
want your kids eating bacon bits and
peanut butter and you're not gonna get
that's at least as bad as seeing Dylan
Mulvaney's the uh face on a
bottle I can it's probably a hell of a
lot worse
they're normalizing just and by the way
you know kids imitate so they're
just gonna be sitting at home with
peanut butter on the counter
smashing it with all kinds of crap in it
and they go I'm stuffing my cup
hey Mom and Dad to go what are you doing
I stuff like well we don't do that at
home we don't stuff our cup at home oh I
stuffed my cup wherever I want I will
stuff my cup wherever I want